the jurogan experience
well there was a moment um
where you were going to come back
you're the og oh
well i mean
gosh there was no you're the og thank
you
in terms of women's mma who the [ __ ] is
more og than you
you're the original star well like not
mma but like lucia ryker yeah for sure
yeah and muay thai yeah and in boxing
yeah and then there's christy martin and
yeah you know a lot of other folks
and then there was like the debbie
purcells and aaron um and wolff
yeah there's been a lot of like women
combat sports athletes but in terms of
mma you're you're the og well i i
appreciate that coming from you that
means a lot i always was it like back
then um
because like you were the og when it was
weird to be fighting and it was weird to
be fighting as a woman yeah
it was just um
you would go into the gym and it was
just uh well we started at master
totties so there was a couple girls
there that really like to fight but they
like to more look good and the attention
that that fighting came from oh yeah um
it wasn't all about like the fight
there's a lot of that now right now it's
like like that but um it was like that
then too um
i don't know a lot of like the what's
her name aaron
god
is debbie purcell and aaron something in
toe hill toe hill yes so they were
actually the people i would say that
started way before yeah aaron was she's
been around a long time and cyborg was
doing it as well um
so tara larosa tara larosa
um old school yeah i can't i know no the
early days we're old
yeah we're old but the early days were
interesting because like you know there
was a lot of uh people disparaging women
fighting yeah you know
including dana white yeah um including
most the guys i trained with which i
love them but you know even mark beecher
he's like no get out of here i'm not
going to train any women okay fine i'll
train you gina it'll be cool but
um and now that's all he does you know
um
you know even uh let's say the diaz boys
like i remember fighting on the same
cars and carter's nick diaz and he was
sitting next to me and of course i was
just nervous because i absolutely adored
him
um still do i think he's amazing i just
haven't seen him in like a decade
but he was like you know we're sitting
there before our fight having our post
you know weigh-in dinner and he was like
you know i got to tell you i don't
really like women fighting
you can obviously say it like that he's
like you know i don't like what you do i
don't like women fighting and i was like
i was like that's okay you know maybe
you're just a little old-fashioned and i
was like do you think my dad likes this
do you think anybody in my family likes
me fighting and he was like
no old-fashioned okay so i'm just
old-fashioned and i'm like yeah you just
might be a little old-fashioned and then
he was like pulling out my chair and
opening my door
he took it to the next level yeah he was
like so sweet i was like he just needed
to be told it's okay you don't have to
like it you know it's old-fashioned so
yeah some people get disturbed watching
women get bloodied up that's a big one
for some folks yeah was it a thing for
you
it feels different obviously i'm a big
fan of women fighting
but
when i watch a big cut on a woman it
feels different like if i said like yuri
prohaska and that fight with glover to
share had this giant cut over his
eyebrow and it's a massive cut
but
it didn't bother me but if that was you
if that was it was a woman it was you
know valentina shivchenko or something
like that i'd be like jesus that's a big
cut and honestly
in my perspective that's sweet
you know wow that's nice
that's nice you don't like to see women
get cut out yeah i think that's a really
nice um i don't know why women or
anybody is trying to get rid of that
well
i get it but i mean that look if you're
going to land elbows it is a part of the
sport you're going to get cut up it's
like people are going to get cut yeah
just part of the game it's
but
you know if you if you want to say that
like here's a good example like the the
last ufc uh where it was uh
zhongweli versus yanion jaycek and then
uh valentino chevchenko
um versus uh jesus christ
why am i not remembering her name
is it the chinese girl that no no no
valentinko had a really tough fight
talia santos
which was an amazing fight split
decision which could have gone either
way um and
a lot of people are like oh this card
sucks i'm like because of those two
fights like you think the card sucks
because two like super ultra competitive
women fights that were insane and one of
them was a spinning back fist knockout
do you have a problem with that
yeah right like i i don't care i don't
understand where people get off on the
internet i'm judging any like when i'm
in a building or at a fight when people
are booing it like it boils my blood
yeah it's like you get in there and do
that you know until you've done that
then you can you know talk about it it's
just like do you boo like that at
baseball because baseball at its most
exciting is not as exciting as two
people clinching yeah maybe the fight
fans just need to like get a couple more
i don't know hot dogs or beers and just
sit back and enjoy a little bit well
it's it's casuals unfortunately you know
it's a lot of people that don't they
don't appreciate what's going on or how
hard it is look i can understand some
fights
where people
get bored and they boo especially in
comparison to some other fights
you know
i'm i'm never going to be the one booing
no i'm wouldn't boo either but
you know there's some times where it's
just like oh jesus christ